Nostalgia is a powerful force, able to warp
people's perceptions.
But you know what they say: you can't go home
again, something that anybody who's tried
to watch their favorite childhood shows as
an adult can confirm.
Sometimes it's best to just leave well enough
alone and not revisit the past, as proven
by these TV shows that have become unwatchable
with age.
Full House
If you were like most kids in the late '80s,
you were probably parked in front of ABC's
family-friendly TGIF block every Friday night.
And your parents probably hated every second
of it, because Full House's saccharine morality
and terrible puns were just flat out hard
to stomach.
“Remember that sausage and lima bean casserole
I made?
I called it my ‘Sunday Surprise.’”
“We called it our ‘Monday Surprise.’”
“I was still getting surprised on Tuesday.”
A hundred terrible catchphrases later...
"You got it dude."
...we're reminded just how awkward and unfunny
the original show was, especially now that
the series' continuation, Fuller House, has
gotten past the first season on Netflix.
"Have mercy."
Xena: Warrior Princess
Xena: Warrior Princess is mainly remembered
for the way it challenged female stereotypes
and the discussions that raged over its lesbian
subtext.
And it also gave the world Lucy Lawless, for
which we offer our heartfelt thanks.
However, the importance of the show has kind
of papered over the fact that it's...not actually
very good, with iffy production values and
clumsy directing.
Not to mention random tonal shifts, like hyper
violence suddenly giving way to musical numbers.
We'll always love Xena the cultural phenomenon.
But the show itself?
Not so much.
Highlander: The Series
Twenty years ago, Highlander: The Series was
about as good as it got for high fantasy.
Now?
We have Game of Thrones.
And once you've seen that, or any other modern
television epic, it's hard to go back to Highlander's
outdated special effects, repetitive immortal-of-the-month
scripts, and one-note acting.
The show kept telling us there could only
be one.
Well… this ain't it.
Saved by the Bell
While '90s spinoffs Saved by the Bell: The
College Years and Saved by the Bell: The New
Class have always been pretty unwatchable,
the original show was once considered essential
television.
Digging out the NBC high school sitcom for
your kids to watch today isn't advisable,
however, as many of the lessons are painfully
dated.
“Haven’t you ever heard of the women’s
movement?”
“Well sure.
Put on something cute and move it into the
kitchen.”
If you want your kids to experience cool high
school entertainment, just buy them some Archie
comics and spare them this horribly out of
touch television.
Walker, Texas Ranger
The fact that Chuck Norris has become a living
parody of this character is almost — but
not quite — enough to prepare you for a
return visit to the unapologetically manly
Walker, Texas Ranger.
While Norris is clearly a skilled martial
artist, he struggles with pretty much everything
else asked of him here.
And he's not the only one.
“And how you doin’ little pardner?”
“Fine, and it’s little visitor now.
Adadamdvhidohi is how you say it in Cherokee.”
“Oooh, well pardon my French, but uh...I’ll
be damned.”
“Walker told me I have AIDS.”
How bad is Walker, Texas Ranger?
One of Conan O'Brien's most beloved comedy
routines is simply playing clips from the
show.
That about says it all.
“My Walker, Texas Ranger lever right here.
Let’s give it a shot and see how it works.”
“Amigo!”
Baywatch
At its height, Baywatch was one of America's
most highly coveted exports, commanding over
a billion weekly viewers from more than 148
countries.
But looking back at the show today it's plain
to see that the skin routinely on display
was literally the only appeal.
With nowhere near enough drama to warrant
an hour-long slot, Baywatch fills the gaps
with copious amounts of running, normally
presented in slow motion to not only capture
the females’ bouncing chests in all their
glory, but to make up for the fact that there
isn't much else going on.
Critics at the time hated it.
It may have taken nearly two decades, but
fans are finally catching up.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!